good morning everyone
we'll bring this meeting of the house
judiciary committee to order
and we'll begin as we usually do with
our pledge of allegiance and perhaps
representative kelly could you lead us
in the pledge of allegiance today sure
you can
i pledge
allegiance of america and to the
republic which stands one nation under
god
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all thank you
be seated
uh
mr clerk would you be willing to call
the role
uh representative gordon
here
representative mcqueen
representative sylvia here
representative walper is here
representative alexander here
representative green
representative notter here
representative merner yeah
representative kelly
representative giusette
here representative andrus here
representative smith
here representative army
representative oregon
mr clerk representative hargan has had a
little
kerfuffle on the road representative
kenny has gone back to get him and they
will be
they're on their way but they'll be a
few minutes late
representative lorenzo yeah
representative chase
representative langley
representative macbeth
representative page here
representative simpson
here
we have 19 members
thank you mr clerk
we do have two members who i understand
are on their way
but we'll begin this morning with house
bill
1073 which is our first item of business
it's an act repealing the right to know
exemption for our attorney-client work
product
and representative wilper do you
have a motion
uh yes mr chairman i will
move out to pass on house bill
1073 with amendment
moved by representative wolper and
seconded by representative sylvia that
this be
recommended as ought to pass with an
amendment and would you like to address
your amendment
uh thank you mr chairman uh
amendment 0689 simply adds a phrase
after the existing
attorney-client privilege or attorney
work product doctrine
exemption
in the right to know act that phrase is
consistent with the public's right to
know
this may be redundant
but considering the history of this bill
this exemption
which came about last spring
after the supreme court had issued
a decision
regarding this exact question of
attorney work product privilege
it's my concern that the courts will now
interpret this exemption without this
qualification
as being a total exemption for anything
that an attorney does anything that
could be considered attorney work
product
would be totally exempt from the
public's right to know
now
they shouldn't be doing that
because a lot of what attorneys do for
us
is not
confidential in any great way in fact
they actually work for the public
but without this
clarification
and considering the way the timing of
when this was introduced
i think this is a necessary
clarification and
that's why i've added it
are there questions or comments
if if i could
represent wolper just
to get it on the record
the
basically the attorney-client privilege
and work product are still exemptions
from the right to know law
but
with your amendment this would qualify
that
so that a determination could be made as
to whether or not there was
whether
the materials that
were considered cl attorney client
privilege or work product
are
or should be made available because they
are otherwise consistent with
the right to know
yes mr chairman it's my intent that the
court
recognized that we're within the right
to know act and that that public does
have a right to know and that
would modify
their application of the attorney client
work product privileges
and i guess if i could just follow up so
that
effectively that means
since i'm not sure exactly
how it would be interpreted ultimately
that would be interpreted by the court
as to what that
means
yes
any other comments or discussion
uh yes
representative macbeth
thank you so i i respect the intent of
the bill it's concerning for me as a
practicing attorney because it's
critical that my clients can ask
questions and share information on a
broad spectrum of issues before i can
provide them counsel and they might some
of the stuff they reveal is personal
some of it
might even you know it
it's it's just
in order to provide the proper advice
um
you really do need to have confident
potentiality or perhaps people will
admit things that are very important
thank you
questions comments
seeing none
we have and this is on the amendment
so this is a motion for adoption of
amendment 0689
and
representative wilpert would you like to
call the role on that
on the acceptance of amendment 0689
representative mclean yes
representative sylvia yes representative
cork vote yes representative court
representative alexander yes
representative green yes representative
notter
representative merner yes representative
kelly yes representative doucette yes
representative andres yes representative
smith
yes
representative army
representative horrigan
is not here i'm sorry representative
diorenzo
representative chase yes
representative kenny who's not here
representative langley
representative macbeth yes
representative page yes representative
simpson yes mr chairman yes
i have the vote at seven
what have i got at 19 to zero
is there any objection to put oh and now
we have
a vote on the underlying bill is there
we now have before us a motion of ought
to pass as amended
and is there any discussion on the
underlying motion
seeing none mr clerk would you like to
call the roll
on out to pass as amended house bill
1073 with amendment 0689 representative
mclean
yes
representative sylvia yes
representative walpole votes yes
representative alexander representative
greene representative notter
representative
representative kelly yes representative
doucette yes representative andrus yes
representative smith yes
representative
representative dilorenzo
representative chase
representative langley
representative macbeth
representative page no
representative simpson
no
mr chairman yes
one two three four five from nineteen i
have
14 in the affirmative
five in the negative
is there going to be a minority report
so this would be on the regular calendar
it'll be on the regular calendar i'd
note that
um representative wolfer will have
will write for the majority and that
representative macbeth will write for
the minority
that's ito representative mcfast
thank you
caacr 18. relating to reproductive
medical decisions providing the state
shall not infringe or unduly
inconvenience the right of reproductive
medical decisions is there a motion
representative
thank you mr chairman i move itl
and is that seconded well second mr
chair
seconded by representative greene
and
would you like to address your motion
well we were all at the hearing and
there was
talk about women's concern for health
and safety
yet there was disdain for the use of an
ultrasound which didn't make any sense
to me because perforation of the uterus
is a risk when a woman gets an abortion
and we know from
that that's not safe and i used to
be a freelance writer freelance
journalist and i've interviewed many
many people
who prayed on the sidewalks and well
that's another bill but um
they they told me they had first-hand
accounts of seeing the ambulance come at
night
where they they take the women away at
night so where's the safety
um
things still happen
and the middle sponsor kept saying said
she wanted to be on the right side of
history she said that more than once and
i just kept thinking about abraham
lincoln and and uh what he when he was
asked
and god's on our side and he said oh my
sir my greatest concern is not whether
god is on our side my greatest concern
is to be on god's side
and
i have a lot of notes on that one bill
i asked the uh
abortionists
about uh
how many late term abortions there i
think that's the other bill though
so i guess it was all said in the
hearing and you were all there so
there's no need to keep talking about it
okay other other
other discussion
yes representative macbeth
thank you so i appreciate my colleagues
comments i won't be voting for the itl i
feel that
the new hampshire people have spoken
when they
overwhelmingly pass the state
constitutional amendment on privacy and
that this is needed just as a
reinforcement um regarding uh the right
to
everyone to exercise their conscious
decisions i mean their their
consciousness when making
um decisions uh of privacy regarding
their spiritual physical and emotional
health so um i'm sorry i won't be
joining you on that and i i urge others
to vote against itl
other discussion
mr chairman yes representative wilper
mr chairman in respect to the
mr chairman was right with respect to
the rights privacy was enacted in our
constitution
that was
right to privacy of personal information
and it said nothing about the right to
take the life of another person
so i don't believe that this at all
comports with that
constitutional amendment and i don't
believe the right to kill babies belongs
in our constitution
yes representative smith
i
i'm slow to get off the
the starting line on this
this is an issue
over which
reasonable caring people
differ
and
we come to this issue with very
different perspectives we come to this
issue with very different understanding
and but i think it is incredibly
important
that we recognize
our obligation to
respect those differences and be careful
in what we say
we cannot assume
that we know
what others believe
and why they believe it and
we can listen and we can respect
one very obvious
issue here is that
i don't know anybody
who thinks um
abortions are absolutely terrific and we
ought to you know play tennis in the
morning and then go have an abortion
i don't think that
anybody
feels that way
i also do not believe
that anyone who believes
an abortion
in
whether it's before 16 weeks which is
all that planned parenthood the planter
would not perform an abortion after that
or 24 weeks
that we are
committing murder in each of those cases
madam chair
i'm sorry mr chair
it's such a feminine issue that's why i
said that
um
we know that
we are talking about
a fetus that can
not survive outside of the woman's body
it cannot survive outside of the woman's
body so that to
until it reaches a certain stage of
development and at that stage of
development there is no one
under
all but the most extreme circumstances
who would agree to
interrupt a pregnancy
to use words like murder
i think are effective if what you want
to do is to play to the audience i don't
think they're effective
if what you want to do is to deal with
the facts
and recognizing that a fetus that cannot
survive outside of the woman
cannot be considered separate from the
woman and her life
and
i know in a bill that's coming up
later
i
deliberately put an amendment language
that my very dear colleague the clerk of
this committee
um proposed about
24 weeks and i did that out of respect
for him
and his concerns and i just hope
that he in turn would respect the
commitment and the intentions
of those people who happen to see this
issue differently
and
i hope i didn't go on too long but
i think it's important to recognize
that
we are going to differ on this issue
and
that's fine
but we should be differing
trying to deal only with facts i'm not
for example going to ask the earlier
speaker to document
where
transportation has come in the middle of
the night to take away bodies i happen
to think there's probably no
justification for that
maybe there is i'm not going to question
that all i'm going to say is that i
think we ought to try to just stick with
the facts
and not do anything more than that thank
you mr chair
representative representative mclean
thank you mr chair so um constitutional
amendments are
very tricky things uh the constitutional
amendment that you referenced you know
representative macbeth
actually went through this house with
multiple sessions laboring over that
language
and actually failed
many times before we were at a place
where we were very comfortable with it
enough to send it off to the voters and
i think that the language in this
particular constitutional amendment is
incredibly incredibly
broad and
this committee recognized that um in the
last session where we had the cacr and
and we rejected it largely for that
reason now the sponsors said that really
roe
we really think that row should be
the floor and we think that maybe we can
go beyond row
but where do you go beyond row
essentially this constitutional
amendment does leave that door wide open
there really hasn't been any discussion
at all
about where would that new ceiling be so
i really think given the breadth of this
amendment
in a post-role world if that were to
come to be um this is just not ready to
go out to the voters at this point and i
i think we as a committee would be wise
to oppose it at this time thank you mr
chair
thank you mr chair
i'm just here as a substitute
and on
but i wanted to make my own background
on this
known
my mother
was
one of very few women
medical students during world war ii
she rotated through
what i would call
abortion wards
they were abortion wards not of people
that had come to get an abortion but of
people who had gone to a back
door
illegal
abortionist
and someone who did not have sufficient
training
they were all dying of sepsis and things
like that you cannot stop abortions
by outlawing them you can only make them
highly unsafe
and i myself spent
25 years working
in third world countries
and i ran into a lot of doctors
that essentially condemned women to
death
by telling them that they would not
help them
in any way but usually it was
contraception that they would not let
them have contraception
but
this
i feel really strongly about this that
that
telling women
that feel that they need abortions
that they cannot have an abortion
is in fact
also possible can could be considered
murder thank you
thank you other questions
comments
mr chairman yes
thank you mr chairman
there's a big difference between
demanding or commanding
an outcome
from a pregnancy and adopting a
constitutional amendment
and
i don't believe
especially considering the diversity of
opinion within this committee and within
our society on this issue i certainly
don't believe it's
appropriate
for a constitutional amendment
other questions or comments
i guess
the only comment i'd have is the cons
the concern i have about the amendment
um this is amending the constitution so
this is something that we should take
very seriously obviously
uh it's not like a statutory change
where could you bring the microphone
closer to mr chairman yes
it's not like a statute where we pass a
statute one year and we don't like it
then we
repeal it the next year then
that can be done and so this is a
constitutional amendment so i think we
need to be concerned about that my
concern with this particular
constitutional amendment is the language
because the language is very broad and
subject i think to broad interpretation
we've all had this discussion about
abortion today but
it doesn't mention abortion at all in
the in the constitutional amendment it
talks about personal reproductive
medical decisions and the question is
how do you interpret that what is that
who's going to interpret that
and
it's sort of like
if you concerned about the second
amendment
our arguments over what does it mean to
bear arms
you know
so i
i'm concerned about the language in it
uh i think the language should be
if we have a specific purpose in doing
the amendment the language should be
more specific
that's my thought
representative
thank you just a brief comment and you
know how much i respect you chairman um
gordon as a jurist and as a chair of
this committee um
you know the the word privacy is not in
the united states constitution and we've
done a pretty good job as the 250 years
have gone i mean we're that's what our
courts do our government i mean we are
an experiment and we have been moving
forward and refining
what those initial
principles meant for
hundreds of years now decades and i
really you know reproductive medical
decisions that's not going to be very
difficult i don't not think to be
defined
and you know unduly inconvenient
it's just as the last um you know
amendment what is privacy and that i
think what's so important about this
amendment
is that it helps the courts define that
and it allows our citizens which when we
look at all of the polling that's coming
in over the last
you know
specifically the last like i think 15
years it's
our citizens are telling us more and
more we want this right they're not
saying we want a certain procedure
that's not what they're saying they're
saying we want the right to make this
decision ourselves because it is so
controversial
because they want it to be private
however they make the decision
that's how i see this and that's why i'm
asking
my colleagues to really look at this
it's it's saying yes something that
affects
our bodies so significantly our
financial our education our lives
forever as far as whether we have a
pregnancy or not whether we have an
abortion whether we give up a child for
adoption all those things are such
significant decisions that they are
private
and that's how they should stay
so thank you for letting me speak and i
appreciate your comments as well
other questions or comments
okay we have
we have a motion of any expedient to
legislate and mr clerk
seeing no further comment would you like
to take the role
on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate
cacr18 representative mclean
yes
representative sylvia yes
representative well provo t.s
representative alexander yes
representative green
representative notter yes representative
merner yes representative kelly
representative doucette yes
representative andres yes
representative smith no
representative
representative yes thank you i have that
representative delorenzo
no
representative chase no
representative langley no
representative macbeth no representative
page no representative simpson no mr
chairman yes
one two three four five six seven eight
what does that make it
attendant
let's be 11 to 8.
11 in the affirmative eight in the
negative
and a minority report
so write the minority report
representative macbeth will write the
return
so we will uh yes mr chairman thank you
i would move out to pass on house bill
1181 with amendment 0744
and is there a second to that
moved by
representative woburn seconded by
representative greene that this be ought
to pass as amended and you want to
address your amendment
i thank you mr chairman
there was
so first of all
it's been understood or although not
widely recognized
that
the the mother's rights
to uh terminate to control her pregnancy
had to be balanced against other things
so the supreme court has explicitly
expressed the idea that at some point in
the pregnancy the state has the uh right
to interfere
in fact it says their duty to interfere
to the point where we can have uh
a ban that we have on in the fetal life
protection act
after viability
what hasn't been specifically addressed
in law
is the father
the father's rights
and it seems to me that naturally the
father would have some right
over
his child
and its life
so this is an attempt
to encode
that right recognizing
that that right is subordinate
to the mother's right
subordinate to the state's right
but it's still a right
that
exists and should be part of the
calculation of what happens
during the uh
hearing on this bill there were several
objections that were raised
and this amendment
addresses those uh objections
concerns
so one of the concerns
was
uh
small thing
well was about what happens if the
juris the jurisdictional question what
if what if one of the parents is out of
state or
so the bill this amendment clarifies
that it has to be within the state of
new hampshire and it's only effective
there
one of the concerns was the notification
provisions where it said the court would
notify
the respondent right well the courts
don't notify respondents so this
amendment clarifies that it will be up
to the plaintiff to
notify the correspondent
one of the concerns was raised about the
legal cost to the mother
this amendment addresses that the father
will now be responsible for all the
legal costs of the mother
another concern was
postpartum care for the mother and this
amendment addresses that as well the
father will provide six weeks of
postpartum medical care so
the only one that isn't addressed by the
amendment per se
was the question of
how do you decide
when
what kind of evidence is necessary for
the father to prove is right is is
worthy of consideration i think is the
way to put that
and and the answer is it's in the
structure of the bill
because the father has to attest has to
swear in his petition
that he believes himself to be the
father
now there's only two ways that this can
go forward
one is that the mother
doesn't dispute
and the other she does if she does the
father can get dna testing
which he has to pay for
which would prove positive
whether or not he's the father
and if it doesn't then it proves he's
not and
there are other
we strengthen the fraudulent claim
portion of this
as well
to penalize uh fraudulent claims
so we believe that all of the objections
that were raised
during the hearing
have been addressed by this amendment
and makes it a strong bill that should
go forward to
identify in law that the father does
have some rights
represent mclean
thank you mr chair so um
i
i really
support the concept of the bill and i i
think that it is
important
that we recognize
um that the father has some kind of
voice um and and to totally take away
that voice um
is is something
that is not right and so the the concept
of the bill i think you know has merit
but when it comes to the standard
when the standard when you say the
standard is really kind of laid out in
the structure of the bill
in this legislation is to maintain
parity it's to give the father some kind
of voice and define what that should be
so i really think that you know while
this amendment goes away over the
original bill i would still recommend
that we we study this and get a better
understanding of what exactly we think
that voice should be but to say the
standard is tied up in the structure i
just don't think that that has enough
clarity for me so i will be opposing the
amendment
representative alexander thank you mr
chair
i i agree with representative mclean um
this clearly needs more study my big
concern is the um
what what happens uh with the court um
there's a lot of language in here saying
that cases shall be heard within a
certain time period
and that concerns me i mean there's a
lot of
timeliness needed in a situation like
this especially during a pregnancy
and then it goes up against our modest
changes in
the six-month
fetal life protection act that we just
put in place and how does that um affect
this legislation as well so i think we
need to study it more um the concept is
okay but i'm i'm still a little
apprehensive i need i need to learn
learn more thank you
other questions or comments
representative chase
thank you mr chair i think i agree
with my two colleagues on this that it
really does need more study i understand
fathers should have rights too but i
also
unfortunately have even had experience
with my own
um
ex-husband of the the fathers sometimes
they do it just because they want to get
back at
the wife or i worry more about the child
who then is going to be born and
supposedly going to be taken care of by
a dad who really is doing it for the
wrong reasons that frightens me so
that's why i would like to have it
studied more find out how many fathers
really have been denied
how many um
i just don't feel as enough check into
the father's background of being a good
parent
to be able to bring this forward and let
them make that decision and take a child
they could decide
it's too much work i don't want to do
this
and that's just how i feel about it
thank you
other comments or questions
representative smith
thank you mr chair um i might have
missed something in in the amendment and
i would ask the
sponsor of the amendment
knowing of his
commitment
to
the product of
a
a reproduction here
i see nothing in this
legislation or in your amendment that
would indicate
any continuing
responsibility on the part of
the putative father
for
the care and upbringing of the um
of
what is now
a baby functioning outside of the woman
so i don't see anything about
about food clothing or shelter of this
product i don't see anything about child
care about access to health care
about any responsibility that any
responsible parent
should undertake
if what we have done is interfered with
a woman's right to control what happens
in her own body
and there is now a product
of that relationship that may or may not
actually be the relationship
and there's no indication that there's
anything that we care about we don't
care seem to care in this about
the baby
we only care
about
the right of someone who brings himself
forward to say he's the father and so
that's my concern what happens if there
is no abortion and then where are we and
i would hope
knowing
that the sponsor is a caring thoughtful
individual
that he
would want to go back to the drawing
board to recognize
a lifelong obligation
to the product of this decision thank
you
other comments or questions
representative chase do you want to
speak again thank you i i just wanted to
clarify what i was saying my ex-husband
i didn't have an abortion we have two
children together who he fought to take
care of
and never did and i was constantly
taking him to court
for child support for helping so that's
what i'm saying here's a guy who fought
fought saying he's going to take care of
these kids and he never
stepped up to the plate that's my fear
it's very hard to raise a child when
they're wondering what happened to their
dad
representative wolper
thank you mr chairman
and i appreciate the thoughtful
responses and concerns that have been
raised
and i'd like to start at the back and go
back to the front
the concern about the well-being of the
child after it's born
the father petitions the court
to become the father in order according
to the bill in order that he may have
and raise the child
once that child is born
the father has sworn
in his petition
that he is the father
and he wants to raise and care for the
child
we have a plethora
of laws that deal with fathers
responsibilities to born children
that does not need to be part of this
bill that isn't the purpose of this bill
and there's no reason why it would be
because they already exist
so
so there's that
as far as uh the other concerns that are
there some of these are difficult to
struggle with
um
i agree how does the court decide when a
minority right
should trump
the more
significant right if i want to call it
that of the mother that's a hard call to
make i don't know how you you encode
that
into any kind of law that's a judgment
call that would have to be made on a
case basis so i don't see that as a
reason for not going forward with this
and with that mr chairman i'll just say
i'll call the role no
actually
i think we should give other people an
opportunity to talk
representative simpson
thank you mr chair
um
i think we're getting at my question but
my question was specifically why under
fraudulent claims it does say that the
man would be required to pay monthly
child support until the child has
obtained the age of 18 years
but it's not mirrored if if there is an
injunction
that same language is not mirrored so if
there's an injunction
the requirement to pay monthly child
support is not
is not also required and i do understand
thank you answered part of my question
representative welper
which is the um
the law does already deal with that
excuse me
i haven't talked much yet this morning
the law does already deal with that but
and my feeling is that there should be a
higher standard for a father who puts
a mother in through this whole
process there might be a higher standard
to their responsibility to
the child
thank you
okay other questions or comments
representative all me
thank you maybe this is covered but i'm
not seeing it
on
assuming that you're talking about
a
ex-boyfriend
that has ill intent
on
could they
on make
this claim just before the woman is
about to have an abortion
and
at that point because she had been
delaying it trying to avoid what she
thought is the necessity
on
trigger the 24-week
ban by the time all of this stuff has
been finished
even if he wasn't the father
we want to answer that question
representative wolf thank you mr
chairman yeah so the bill says that the
whole thing has to pre has to proceed
in such a way that we don't violate the
existing law of 24 weeks so if the
woman's uh
close to that and then petition comes
forward i'm pretty confident the court
would just say
we can't deal with this in the time
before we would be violating the law and
according to this bill
we can't deal with it
but
they have that right thank you on i
couldn't find it but i'm not a lawyer
anyone else want to comment
i guess
my thought
on it was
uh as far as the amendment is concerned
the amendment probably improves what was
originally presented and i really
wouldn't have any problem
voting for the amendment itself
and the the other part of it is i i
think i agree that in some respects
a
the
male portion
should have a voice of some type
and
but
it's the mechanics that are the problem
here you know how does that how do you
make that happen
and i just don't think at this point in
time
this bill is ready with regard to
properly forming the
mechanics of
giving that person the voice
and i think it would require a little
bit of
and
but i think it's something that we
should study and we should look at and
make sure that we come up with the right
product
anybody else
so we have a motion this is a motion on
the amendment amendment 0744
and mr clerk you now can call the roll
i thank you mr chairman on the adoption
of amendment
0744 to house bill 81.
representative mclean
uh yes on the amendment but i will be
voting no on the bill
representative sylvia yes
representative walpervolts
representative alexander yes
representative green yes representative
notter yes representative merner yes
representative kelly
representative doucette yes
representative andrus yes representative
smith
no
representative all me
representative horrigan
i'm sorry representative delorenzo no
representative chase yes
representative langley
representative macbeth
representative page no
representative simpson no
mr chairman
yes
one two three four five six seven
so i have it um
we got nineteen twelve to seven one two
three four five six seven eight
so we've adopted amendment 0744 now we
would be voting on the
underlying bill as amended
yeah comments with regard to the
underlying bill
again i shared the
concern that was expressed by my vice
chair
representative mclean and that is i
think the amendment is an improvement
but i i think this requires more study
and would vote against the ought to pass
and hope a alternative motion would be
made after that
anyone else wish to comment or
see none
call the roll
on house bill 1181
ought to pass with amendment 744
representative mclean
no
representative sylvia yes
representative well proposed he asked
representative alexander no
representative greene yes
representative notter
representative
[Music]
representative kelly
representative giusette yes
representative andrus no
representative smith
representative army
representative
di lorenzo no
representative chase no
representative kenny no representative
langley now
representative macbeth no
representative page no
representative simpson no
mr chairman
two three four five six so i have a
seven in the affirmative 12 in the
negative
the motion
the motion of octopass is amended has
been defeated
representative would you like to make an
alternative motion i will so uh mr
chairman i would like to move interim
study
i'll second that motion
any further
discussion seeing none
you can call the roll
on house bill 1181 to interim study
representative mclean yes
representative sylvia yes
court votes yes representative alexander
yes representative greene
representative notter
representative merner
representative kelly
representative doucette yes
representative andres yes representative
smith
yes
representative almi
representative diorenzo
yes
representative chase
representative langley yes
representative macbeth
representative page yes
representative simpson
yes
mr chairman
so i have 18 in the affirmative one in
negative
do you want to do a minority report
representative
um
is there any objection to being on the
consent calendar
no
no objection
going to move on to the
to
the last bill if i can and that would be
an act relative to reproductive rights
mr chairman
yeah
representative alexander would you like
to make a motion um i would mr chair i'd
like to uh move hb 1674 and expedient to
legislate
and is that seconded
representative wolfer is that one second
thank
all right you busy trying you're ahead
of me i had to have the bills thank you
mr clark for doing that
you want to
address your motion please uh
pardon a lot of my concern lies in
section one of the bill um it shall be
public policy new hampshire that because
it is vital to the equality and liberty
of all individuals
we're forgetting the equality of liberty
of the unborn in this legislation
this legislation also creates a separate
um right of action against the state for
injunctive relief
typically i've in the past been opposed
to
adding new causes of action against the
state i think the existing laws would
provide for
relief
so for that reason i just hope my
colleagues follow me and vote and
expedient legislate thank you
representative simpson did you yeah yes
please thank you
um
thank you mr chair i'll be voting
against the itl on this bill
i'd just like to say that multiple
generations of women and girls have had
access to safe legal abortion since roe
v wade was decided 49 years ago
it's highly likely that roe v wade will
be overturned by the supreme court this
year if that happens the rights of women
and girls in new hampshire
will no longer be protected federally
this bill would would ensure what
already exists here in new hampshire
access to safe legal abortions for women
and girls
up until the current ban in statute at
24 weeks
the new 24-week abortion ban
is in statute and i'm asking we are
asking that the rights of women and
girls be placed in law next to the
restrictions
thank you
okay other questions comments
mr chairman yes representative walper so
the first question i have is
reproductive rights
it seems to me that reproductive rights
means the right to reproduce
is is that right
i mean
it seems to me that reproduction occurs
at the time of conception
and after conception we're no longer
talking about reproductive rights we're
talking about some other kind of rights
like the rights to medical treatment or
something
right which don't have actually anything
to do with reproduction because it's
already occurred
representative simpson would you like to
respond to that
yes i would thank you
abortion care is a form of health care
and the reproductive system
is a system that is part
of all of us but i'll speak for myself
as a woman the reproductive system and
all that
happens within it and belongs to it is
um
includes the entire spectrum of care
related to the reproductive system so i
don't think that
rights to reproduction
is only about
the moment of conception
representative wolper
so
accepting that
if we if we enact this would a child of
say
have the right to reproduce
that would be
i would say guaranteed
i
i respectfully don't believe that that
is the part of the bill
i'm not going to address that here
i'm happy to have that conversation with
you afterwards though representative
walper
other discussion
yes representative simpson
i do want to say on a somewhat related
note
that this bill would
make sure that if a 13 year old
were
pregnant that she would have access to
abortion care under the law
representative langley did you have a
quote no
any other questions or comments
seeing none
we have a motion of inexpedient to
legislate representative
wilper would you like to take the role
on the motion of house bill 1674
inexpedient to legislate representative
mclean
yes
representative sylvia
representative
yes representative alexander yes
representative greene
representative notter yes representative
mirner yes
representative kelly
representative doucette yes
representative andrus yes representative
smith no
representative army
representative di lorenzo no
representative chase
representative kenny is not here
representative langley
representative macbeth
representative page no
representative simpson
no
mr chairman yes
i have it at two four six eight eleven
two eight two four six nine eight yep
sam right that's correct okay i've been
11 in the affirmative eight in the
negative so we on house bill 1674 we've
adopted the recommendation of an
expedient to legislate would there be a
minority report
yes
and that would be
otp
out to pass yes
whatever phone call conversation find
out if people can get here yeah uh my
understanding is that they are nearby
maybe parking at this very moment so why
don't we why don't we recess until uh 20
past and then we reconvene
okay so we've done
this one
maybe
we'll call the house judiciary committee
back to order
and uh welcome our two members who uh
were unable to be here earlier
and the clerk can note that they are now
in attendance
the next item of business is house bill
and is there a motion this is an act
prohibiting abortions after detection of
fetal heartbeat is there a motion
representative langley
thank you mr chair i would move in
expedient to legislate
on health bill 1477
and is there a second
seconded by representative chase
and representative langley do you want
to address your motion
not to belabor other points that have
been made this morning up to uh this
point in terms of abortion but i would
direct people to uh line number nine
in the document and it talks about
the unborn human individual and line
number ten says from fertilization until
live birth i think if we implemented
this law that it would ins it would undo
the ban that we currently have
on the 24 week abortion and bring it
from the date of conception on
the other comment that i would make is
in terms of
a heartbeat there's a lot of electronic
responses that can be picked up
from a person's cardiology from
at any point in their life and that
could easily be misconstrued as a
viable heart thank you
other questions comments
representative mclean
thank you mr chair um
i
i think that you know this this
legislation um
really does kind of go up
against roe and
but i'm going to support it anyway
because i really think that this
legislation is very
timely because it's addressing
the question
of
where we place value and how do we place
value on the fetus and how does that
value
evolve and you know if i could just
kind of illustrate a point by not going
back to roe but by going back to a
different supreme court case 170 years
ago when we looked at the dred scott
decision the dred scott decision was
probably the most horrible decision that
the supreme court ever brought forth in
which a black man who was living free
dred scott was essentially
put back into
slavery and you ask yourself how could
that happen
with the people on the supreme court
just not smart
how could that have happened and what
the reason it was able to happen really
is not that they were dumb but it's
where they placed value and they did not
place
value on dred scott a black man the way
that they placed value on a white man he
had value for sure but more as property
like your toyota tacoma or something
like that now you fast forward in time
170 years to where we are now
we go back and for all the problems that
we have in this country there's nobody
in in this room in this state house in
this state that would ever defend the
dred scott decision
and the reason for that is that our
understanding of our humanity has
evolved and we understand that
regardless of our skin color we are all
equally human now we go back and we look
at the row decision
where did the row decision assign value
the row decision assigned value with the
privacy of the woman which i think is is
a great thing you know women should have
privacy and it also acknowledged that a
woman has sovereignty over her own body
which is again something that i could
really get behind and defend and when it
was put against the fetus they said well
maybe later on in the pregnancy
we have to have something but we
certainly
don't want to subordinate these rights
of women if all we're subordinating it
to is essentially
a bunch of cells
and if that was the case
i would be the number one defender of
roe
but i don't think it is the case
and 50 years on our understanding of the
fetus
has really evolved and as
our understanding has evolved and got
much better with all this technology our
value the value that we place on the
fetus has gone up and up and up and it
doesn't matter if the heartbeat
at seven weeks is a real heartbeat or um
it's just electrical impulses
what it's an indication of and what
we're understanding now is it's an
indication of an individual
human entity and so what happens is not
that our value of a woman's privacy or
sovereignty over her body has gone down
but just that our value of the fetus
goes up and up and up the more we learn
so at this point in time where
everything really is in flux
this bill i think is a very important
bill for reassessing that value and and
i think we should support it thank you
mr chair
other questions or comments
representative horrigan
thank you mr chair and thank you for
your patience uh i apologize for being
late but um
the
um what's what it says in the state
constitution the federal constitution
they talk about the inalienable rights
that humans have it's always uh from
birth and um so our
i mean our understanding
our knowledge about uh
embryonic and fetal develops more than
there was before but the theory that
they had back then was its broad
outlines pretty similar to what we have
now so i think the constitutional
provision about birth still still
applies especially given that um
a large percentage of uh large a large
percentage of pregnancies um don't go to
term anyway even even in the absence of
a you know deliberate abortion so that's
uh
um
i think so if we pass this law that kind
of muddies the waters a bit because it's
a definition unborn human individual
which is from conception and i
understand why that's appealing to a lot
of people but that's
inconsistent with what uh
our constitutional other law has said
for for centuries so that's
that's uh
that's one reason why i'll be voting
against this bill thanks
representative chase thank you mr chair
and i just wanted to address what uh
representative maclean was saying
you just mentioned about noises
basically that maybe a heartbeat may not
be this is about having a fetal
heartbeat how are you just saying that
when it's a bunch of cells and you can
hear noise
you're considering that a heartbeat i
just want to make sure i was clear of
what you're saying
i'm saying
that there was testimony in the public
hearing that um
when they are detecting the fetal
heartbeat was it a fully formed heart
and um
i think
that
obviously it's not a fully formed heart
because at six weeks you can't survive
outside of the womb but it doesn't mean
that it's not a heart and it doesn't
mean that there isn't something that is
going on from an electromagnetic
perspective
even if it's not a fully formed heart
representative nader thank you mr
chairman
and thank you representative maclean for
what you said i agree with you one
hundred percent
dr seuss said a person is a person no
matter how small and the feed the word
fetus is a latin word that means little
one
and you had mentioned slavery which of
course is a horrible thing
horrible horrible thing we all know that
now and i i think maybe someday people
in the future will look back to
us
in today's world and wonder how we ever
could have supported
abortion so i know this bill is not
going to pass but i i can't vote against
it so
i support it
other questions or comments
represent well me
thank
you i was
when i passed
i grew up in the time
when
if you were became of reproductive age
and you were female you were
either
highly constrained
couldn't
you had to always think
if i do something
something wrong or walk down the wrong
street go out at night etc
i might end up
yes with a child but with a child that
established what my the next 18 years at
least of my life was going to be
assuming that i survived the pregnancy
this is not just a matter of privacy
it's a matter of enslavement of women
and that's what it felt like in those
days
and that's what
you're trying to get it back to and i
think
that there is
i know from the polling that this state
does not agree
with this bill
maybe it would head in that direction i
hope i won't be alive at that point
thank you
okay representative alexander thank you
mr chair um personally when it comes to
these issues i don't really care what
public polling says this is really a
personal moral issue
to each and every individual
what i would say this is that at the end
of life when doctors determine when the
end of life is it is
when the heartbeat stops
so i'm just asking we have the same we
treat life at the beginning when the
heartbeat starts that is when life
begins and the state has an obligation
to protect life so at the end of life
i'm asking we have the same
application at the beginning thank you
other comments questions
representative lorenzo
thank you mr chairman
i just have a comment that
there's been a lot of talk throughout
this country throughout this state about
self-determination and against
government mandates
if this bill were passed then
there would be a mandate prohibiting
women from having abortions
and i think it's wrong thank you
thank you
any other questions or comment
representative langley
i've just thank you mr chair just one
final comment
and
it goes beyond this particular bill i
think to some of the testimony that
we've heard as we've gone along
this session around
vaccination
and covet and how people have responded
to that
and i've listened as people have come in
and they've been very articulate and
very passionate
about saying how they felt about their
freedom being violated because
there has been encouragement either to
wear a mask or become vaccinated etc and
that they needed to make their own
choice
i just find it really exceptionally
confusing when i think about
right to life issues abortion issues and
reproductive issues
that as a woman i'm not able to make
that decision in consultation with
whoever is most significant in my life
in my physician thank you
thank you mr chairman
there's a lot to be said here so i'd
like to follow a couple different
threads
the first one is where representative
mclean started but i don't want to start
what he did
i want to go back to the foundation of
our country and the declaration of
independence
this country was founded
founded
on the idea
that
we're endowed by our creator
with inalien unalienable rights
and among those rights are the right to
life
life is not created by us
life is created by our creator
and that life is an unalienable right
according to the declaration of
independence
unalienable that means it cannot be
separated
from your own self
when it is it is and forever protected
as an unalienable
right
according to that
life began and we know
from embryology
that life
human life
every life begins at conception
not at six weeks not at 16 weeks or 24
weeks it begins at conception so if this
is unalienable right
and it begins at conception it should be
protected from conception
now it's true we don't know
when
that human life actually begins
in the sense that we don't have any way
of
of identifying
that that life exists
right as we've heard now the testimony
women don't know they're pregnant for
weeks after the time that they become
pregnant but they are and the life has
been living within them
for that period of time
the purpose of government
is to secure our rights back to the
declaration of independence
so why isn't it for i believe it is the
purpose of government to protect human
life
when you get to dred scott
the supreme court said
that class of people
are not human
and denied
their inalienable right to life
denied their very humanity
when we come to roe versus wade
the supreme court said
we don't know
we don't
know
what that thing in the womb
is
and so
we're going to say
that a woman
has the right to control that thing in
her womb she owns it
but now we do know
we do know and as the supreme court said
in roe versus wade if we did know
that
product of conception
would be protected
because it has the unalienable right to
life
and we sit here today
knowing
and argue about
well
just because it's not a real heartbeat
are you kidding me
we know what that is that's a person it
can be nothing else
p
every organism reproduces after its own
kind a woman does not bring forth a
grapefruit
or a sheep
she brings forth another human being
and it deserves
the protection of its unalienable right
and with that i'll just
say
that if we look at the what we're doing
in that light
then the regime that has allowed over 60
million babies to be killed
killed intentionally killed that's what
abortion is intentional killing of its
baby allowed over 60 million
human beings to be killed
with no protection
is the greatest human rights violation
of all time
and i'll be supporting the bill
representative nader
thank you mr chairman they knew what
that thing was in the year 70 a.d in the
teaching of the 12 i'm going to spell it
d-i-d-a-c-h-e i pronounced it did it say
could be wrong it says in chapter 2 that
you shall not
murder you shall not procure an abortion
representative green
to add on what's already been said just
a couple of from my own perspective
about half a lifetime ago my wife and i
were trying to conceive
and we were not able to
and
in all this discussion there's this
from what we've heard today from what we
heard last week in rep's hall
there's
just virtually no discussion about
the alternative adoption
adoption attorney told us 30 years ago
that for every healthy infant available
there's a hundred couples that want it
so
we we couldn't adopt it just there's
just too many obstacles we couldn't do
it now a lot of people are successful
and it's become easier over the years
with
when we did it was pre-internet and now
there's much more of a phenomenon of
international adoption and all that but
back in the day that's what we're up
against so
that's
i mean
that was the first thing
that helped me evolve
on this issue
and i i think the second thing is i just
think of myself from recent years
we as a society
we need to
answer the ultimate question
does that growing
human being in a woman's body does it
have value
either it does
or it doesn't
and i'll close with that
any other comments representative
lorenzo thank you mr chairman um one of
the
former speakers here
mentioned the inalienable rights
in our constitution um
and he said life
liberty and pursuit of happiness
so it's a three it's a three-part
right
liberty
allows us to make decisions about our
own bodies
the pursuit of happiness
um allows us to make decisions about our
own bodies
thank you mr chair
other questions or comments
representative simpson
thank you mr chair um and i'd i'd just
like to refer back to
a comment from my colleague um and just
to say
uh representative walper if i may how
much i deeply respect your faith and
your commitment to this issue and
would like to state that i
myself
have a deep faith
in my creator and that that is very
important to me
but i would also like to speak for those
whose faith may differ from mine
and who may
differ from yours
and may have their own faith that i
think it's really important that we
allow
individuals women who are pregnant
to
make the decisions that they need to
make based on the law that we have in
statute
the decisions that they need to make
based on their own
religious life their own faith their own
spiritual life if they
do have that or not if they don't that
they are able to make decisions based on
their own
weighing their own factors in their
lives that are important to them and to
their families and to their communities
and
to the people in their lives thank you
representative oregon thank you very
much mr chair and i um
the we we we were yeah reverend welper
recently he started with the idea which
he thought was universal is that
there is a creator but that's even
that's not a universally shared opinion
um
and even if you know there
even if there was a creator who being
who's somehow similar to us human beings
we don't necessarily know what his her
it's uh their
agenda is so it's pretty presumptuous to
like uh you know
to just sort of seem that a creator
would definitely take uh you know
the position that the sponsors bill's
doing in the issue and certainly
every species uh
you know every species you know
uh produces you know a lot more uh you
know conceives you know a lot more
individuals than are actually actually
born the human you know the humans um
humans we actually have one of the
highest success rates you know like
because most most uh
most babies are born who are conceit
most you know most uh you know conceived
um
embryos uh do eventually develop in a
reasonably healthy human being we're
pretty rare in that regard so i um
anyway i just just want to say the
whether or not you're as a creator
doesn't really uh
doesn't really have much to do whether
or not this bill is a good idea and i
believe it's a bad idea so thanks
other questions or comments
it's been an excellent debate here but
it's a debate that not only happens here
it happens everywhere with
people having differences of opinion
honest differences of opinion
and i have great respect for
my dear clerk next to me who does all
the work and i take all the credit um
and
and and for all sides of the argument i
guess the way i've tried to think about
this and and
it's
it's putting together
my good clerk's argument about
when does life actually started
if it starts at conception and you
believe it starts at conception
and you believe it shouldn't be taken
then i'm not sure deciding that when it
has an electrical pulse is the right
time to decide whether
it should be terminated
i think if you intellectually look at it
it shouldn't be terminated at all as
opposed to at that particular given time
so
and the
we've just passed this law that says uh
that
you can't have uh
a board of services after 24 weeks and
which has only been been in effect less
than two months at this point in time
which appears to be reasonable and
clearly we can pass reasonable
restrictions on abortion
i'm not sure saying
that six weeks is reasonable
if you believe
and i know you wouldn't believe but if
you do believe that women should have a
reasonable choice at some point in time
i just think
six weeks probably isn't
that right time
and so
i'm gonna vote against the bill
on that basis and just want to let
everybody know that
any other comments or questions
okay mr clerk we have a motion of
inexpedient to legislate on house bill
1477.
on the motion of house bill 1477
inexpedient to legislate representative
mclean
no representative sylvia no
representative walper votes no
representative alexander no
representative green
representative
no representative
no
representative kelly
representative doucette no
representative andres no representative
smith yes
representative
representative oregon yes representative
diorenzo yes representative chase yes
representative kenny
representative langley yes
representative macbeth yes
representative page yes representative
simpson yes
mr chairman yes i have an 11 in the
affirmative 10 and a negative
and
and the minority report represented
mclean you're going to do a minority
report
you might be ought to pass
yes
hospital 1625 an act repealing the
uh the prohibiting on entering or
remaining on a public way or sidewalk
adjacent to a reproductive health care
facility
and is there a motion representative
page
make a motion
itl please
and is there a second
seconded by representative smith
and representative page you want to
address your motion yes thank you mr
chair um
i think the current
buffer zone we have in place
satisfies constitutional muster but let
me back up and say that
i certainly understand that um the first
amendment freedom of speech is
a protected right certainly and
certainly when it relates to civil
political discourse
or opinions but it's not an unfettered
right and it's not unfettered right even
when that speech is exercised on the
sidewalk
we heard testimony
regarding new hampshire's
law
dealing with a buffer zone
that in my view
is the new hampshire way
we heard how it was carefully crafted
to respond to
the supreme court's decision mccollum
which had struck down
portions of the massachusetts law
like many things from our
southern neighbor new hampshire we do a
little bit better
and and this bill has our current buffer
law
has the flexibility that responds to the
supreme court
it's a flexible bill flexible law as it
is in existence right now
it's certainly distinguishable from
the mccullen case which is what the
current bill relies on
and yesterday we heard the governor even
talk about how the new hampshire way of
responding flexibly
to certain elements is an important
value that we cherish here in new
hampshire and the current law does that
um
and i also think that through the
testimony we also heard some pretty
compelling testimony from
the doctors who
talked about what impact
folks who are on the sidewalks are
saying to them as they enter
a facility and
that doctor tollen in particular had
mentioned that in her view
all the women that had entered
facilities had gone through
different levels of analysis about what
has to be
a weighty decision
and in fact
more disturbing to them was
after having gone through that
they entered the facility
almost traumatized i believe she used
that word
so they had thought about that decision
but in some i think
like i said before
this bill our current law
is flexible it responds to mccallen it
was crafted with the notice of what the
supreme court had said
about the massachusetts law
and for those reasons i think it is it
is what we've heard about as a new
hampshire way we're doing things
that are flexible and that makes sense
that's why i urge folks to itl the
current bill
representative mclean thank you mr chair
um
as as you wrap mentioned uh
representative paige d
the the right to free speech is not
completely
um
unlimited
but
if you are going to place restrictions
on free speech then you really have to
demonstrate a compelling need to do so
there has to be
a really good reason and in
the
years i think it was 2014 since this law
was enacted
we have
a dozen clinics i believe from the
testimony
in this state that provide abortion
services
yet in all that time
they have never
taken advantage
of this statute and you know i've been
in the committee long enough
to see people from various
reproductive health centers come in and
i would ask them the question in fact
last year you may recall there was a 72
year old woman
who testified that she would be an
escort which would she would escort the
woman into the clinic and she was saying
oh it's terrible the amount of abuse i
get and there's people over in in the
other buildings and they're filming and
things like that so i asked
the
the manager of that clinic
why in this situation she hadn't take
advantage of the very powerful
provisions of this law and you know she
says well we're still working out
something
with the with the local police and
to this day there still has
nothing been enacted so i would argue
that
the compelling need
in order to put these restrictions on
speech
just has not been uh demonstrated and so
based on that i'm going to support the
bill thank you
other questions comments representative
notter
thank you mr chairman and again i agree
with
representative mclean 100
also this wouldn't be the first time i
mean i know this bill isn't going to
pass but um we did um remove
a law that that was not enforced that
was
used to be illegal to warm up your car
in the morning and we argued like well
if you have a baby don't you want to
warm up the car in the morning
you know you're not supposed to put the
jackets on
on the baby but that's another issue but
we did repeal that because it didn't
make any sense it wasn't enforced so
this is another
law that's not enforced so why have it
represented kenny
uh yeah thank you mr chairman um so i i
fully understand that it has not been
used
but attacks are on the rise across the
country human nature is human nature and
new hampshire is not immune to that
potential and it's a tool
in the toolbox that if it is ever needed
it's there um
if you own a house and it hasn't caught
fire in six years you don't throw out a
fire extinguisher just because you
haven't used it yet you'll be very happy
it's there
if a fire does come and
i believe that
having that in the toolbox is only going
to be useful if we ever
have situation where granite staters
need to be protected despite uh what
your beliefs are on reproductive justice
it has nothing to do with that has to do
with keeping granite staters safe if
that is ever necessary thank you
other representative horrigan
thank you very much i was
a member of the committee when we
passed when we passed this bill through
committee and um we did
well i was part of a small group i
didn't i was
my contribution was fairly small i would
give a special uh especially the line
share credit to representative birch who
i hope is recovering well and i hope is
possibly watching us on youtube but we
were very as reverend page correctly
said we were very well aware of the uh
what was going on with the massachusetts
law and uh we tried to tailor it to uh
meet the objections that the uh
that the uh that have been uh that the
mass that had overturned the
massachusetts law with the mccullen
versus coakley supreme court case so we
were well aware of that so we were uh
we did make a lot of
tweaks me not me so much mostly paul and
some others who worked on it but i was i
was part of the subcommittee but and um
the uh
other thing is we
um there's certainly a right for them to
express their opinion um but
you aren't necessarily allowed to
express your opinion exactly where you
want to and certainly if you're blocking
the the entrance to a
healthcare facility whether it's because
you're opposed to abortion or vaccines
or anywhere else that's uh not a
constitutional right there you do it
and so there's no constitutional rights
to harass or impede and
also it's often representing that's
providing counseling to the potential
patients who are
coming to the clinic and there's also no
no right to provide for unlicensed
counselors to uh operate on the sidewalk
and um there's
certainly a lot of questions about uh
how well how well they're trained
whether
and um
sir i know the escorts by the way have a
pretty extensive training program and
they're you know they respect uh you
know
they protect the patient's privacy
rights and so forth so they have a
pretty extensive
program it's really unclear
what the counselors are but in any case
there is no
there is no legal or constitutional
right to provide unlicensed counseling
services on the sidewalk
so
that's uh
that's just a couple perspective i want
to add a couple more reasons why we
should
keep the law in place and and kill this
bill thanks
other questions comments
actually representative sylvia
thank you mr chairman and i'm reminded
by the gentleman from durham
that
this bill
and keeping it in play the the law and
keeping it in place
keeps the people divided
it keeps people from being close enough
to talk to each other and have a civil
conversation
and i'd rather have the civil
so i'm going to oppose the itl
representative wilbur
uh thank you mr chairman first i'd like
to uh uh just
the
representative from durham said there's
no
um law
protecting unlicensed counseling
on the street
which is quite true
however there's a lot of different um
levels of counseling
counsel
is what's used for giving advice
which is more along the lines of what
the people
who are outside the clinic do
than anything else
they inform and advise
women
of their options
and encourage them to take advantage of
the options
available to them
but
and the supreme
when we talk about freedom of speech and
when it can be curtailed
there are certain attributes the supreme
court uses to make these decisions
and one of them is
is the speech
being curtailed
content neutral or is the curtailment
content specific
and if it's content specific
that's not really an allowable reason
for curtailing speech
in this option situation the speech is
at 100 percent content specific if they
don't care if you want to go out and
talk about
various civil rights or
who won the football game on the
sidewalk that's just fine you could
stand out there and it wouldn't be a
problem
it's because
the speech that they're trying to
prohibit
would take away their customers
so this law provides
protection
for the private businesses
that are in the business of killing
babies
that that's not tolerable to me
so i would vote against it
just for that reason
representative kenny
ah yeah thank you um i just want to
respond um to the civil
conversations because it is a great
sentiment um but that is not every
person
there uh some do want to pray i do know
we got testimonies with people with good
intentions um but it's it's a distance
of two parking spaces and if somebody
wants to engage and seek advice
the civil conversation can happen
but
everyone is not civil um
that that is just a fact and i believe
two parking spaces
allows freedom of speech to still
be totally present and allows someone to
go to a medical procedure without being
harassed um
because it does happen and
we will be happy to have this tool in
the toolbox if it's needed thank you
representation
i was going to say about the same thing
that what we're talking about is getting
in someone's face and telling them
things they don't want to hear
representative chase
thank you i think in this day and age
women are
aware of what their choices are i'm not
saying they may be
in depth of the
amount of knowledgement but but you know
you can
put a baby up for adoption you know you
can go through with a pregnancy and you
can also have the option of not having a
pregnancy for the reasons that you have
personally decided and talked to with
the people you love
i don't
unders i understand the praying i don't
know how many people are really
taken by listening to someone saying no
come over here and talk to us about it i
know there are people that are on the
fence absolutely hundred percent it's a
terrible thing
when you have to face it no matter what
it's not a pleasant
a present procedure it's not something
that doesn't affect your life it does
but i don't
feel that
the being yelled at or being um even i
don't know maybe i don't want to sit and
pray
that's my personal choice it's your
personal choice just to be there if i
needed help or guidance i can come over
and see you i'm just don't um
i don't know i don't is is the concept
that you that
pro-life people think that the um
people who are having abortions the
women don't understand there i'm asking
a question to you don't understand what
their options are what
i'm sorry
representative
would you volunteer to address that
that's an excellent question i'm really
glad you asked it
because first of all you need to speak
into your microphone because first of
all
post-aborted women
by an enormous majority
report that if they had had any support
at all
they would not have done their abortions
so
one of the things
that the
counselors on the sidewalk do is they
inform women that there is support for
them that they did not know existed
before
that's one of the biggest reasons that
they save substantial number of lives
every single year
because they just offer help and support
to the pre-abortive woman
yes representative smith
thank you mr chair i've
sat here and listened
to deeply held views
that are disparate one from another and
i know in this committee we have
respected
those views and we respect each other
and
i chose not to add
to the conversation
but i do have to respond to what my
dear colleague just said
i have said before and i will say again
that each of us is entitled to our own
opinion
we are not
entitled
to our own facts
and i would suggest
to the distinguished clerk of this
committee
that the statement that he just made
is
not
accurate it is not verifiable and it
doesn't do credit to him
when he makes such
moving
personal statements
without
trying to bring in
[Music]
statements that are not
verifiable and i would hope that each
one of us
would refrain from that
there is nothing that any one of us on
this committee in this legislature in
this state or country or world can do
to end abortions
abortions have existed as long as
procreation
has existed
we are not going to end that we might by
providing adequate
education to our children about how to
avoid getting pregnant when it's not
appropriate for them
education would help it might help if we
had
availability of contraception
to again prevent pregnancies when it is
not wanted or appropriate all of those
are probably more significant in
avoiding abortion
than
us believing that we can pass a law or a
rule or make a decision that is going to
end abortion
that is not
going to happen
and i would suggest
that
the differences in our views are valid
and understandable
but please
don't invent facts don't use statements
from one source or another that you
yourself haven't verified
i have mentioned before and i will
mention again the very first year i
served on this judiciary committee in
one of my colleagues who was then um a
very young man who i think had just
finished college or he might have been
his senior year
announced that women
he said girls
that girls get give up their um
go to get an abortion because they can't
fit into a prom dress
and i asked him if he could please give
me the names and addresses of those
women because i would like to speak with
them and of course he could not
and i would suggest to you that your
statement that says
that most women who have had abortions
regret that and had the abortion because
they didn't know they had a choice
i'd suggest you that that is not
factually accurate and i would hope that
you would try not to use those kinds of
of statements because i don't think it
does credit to your deeply held views
thank you
you have the opportunity to respond if
you want okay
the um
any other questions comments
the only thing i'd uh say is that
uh and
i don't i don't support the bill and
you know i've given it quite a bit of
thought because
ultimately i
think that restrictions particularly in
public places should not be something
that should be taken lightly and we
shouldn't engage in in general
but we have and we do we impose a
restriction for example on our as having
been a town moderator for many years we
impose a buffer zone on entering the
polls
and we do that because there are people
who are adamant about their particular
positions
who
would make an effort to encounter voters
as they come to the polls and we've
indicated that we don't feel that those
voters
should have to run a gauntlet in order
to come to vote and exercise what they
have a right to do
and so it isn't as if we haven't in the
past exercise buffer zones there are
other buffer zones too which i don't
need to go into a description
but ultimately the question comes down
to this and uh as as it does i think for
me with all legislation because i
skip buoy standard who is a electrician
in my town he says ned please don't vote
for anything
until you figure out if it's really
needed and
right now
i don't think this re
is needed because i think it's working
pretty well
and when i listen to the testimony that
we had over in representatives hall
the question is what would people do
differently
than they're doing right now
and i heard from a lot of very
wonderful people who are out
in
in front of the facilities that we're
discussing who are doing their very best
to counsel people if they have the
opportunity to communicate with people
to do those things but the question is
what would they do
differently
and
i'm not sure that they would do anything
differently
i mean they're still going to be as from
what i can see for the most part
courteous
people
doing their job so
long and the short is i think keeping a
buffer to prevent
unwanted communications makes sense to
me and i'm going to
vote against the bill itself and
for the itl
representative alexander um sorry mr
chair one more thing um the question
behind this is um
proponents for the repeal of this buffer
zone would say it's unconstitutional
um advocates for the buffer zone would
say we've never used it because for one
reason or another
my question is is let's see if
if it's used let's file a lawsuit and
let's have the courts determine whether
this is constitutional or not it's been
struck down in other states so i would
say like until the buffer zone is used
there's really no need to repeal it at
this point thank you
any other questions or comments
mr clerk you want to call the roll
on the question of house bill 1625 being
inexpedient to legislate representative
mclean
no
representative sylvia no representative
walper votes no representative alexander
yes
greene
representative notter
representative merner
representative kelly
representative doucette no
representative andres no
representative smith yes representative
army
representative oregon yes
representative diorenzo yes
representative chase yes representative
kenny yes representative langley yes
representative macbeth
representative page
representative simpson yes
mr chairman yes
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten five twelve i have it at 12 in the
affirmative nine in the negative
we've adopted the recommendation of
inexpedient to legislate representative
page you need to do the majority report
and
represent mclean will you do a minority
report
yes
house bill 1673
an act relative to women's health
privacy and repealing the fetal health
protection act
representative
actually representative
wolfer would you like to make a motion
thank you mr chairman i would move on to
pass as amended
on house bill 1673
with amendment
eight 0688
oh six eight eight
yeah so six eight eight
and is that seconded
i can second in mr chair
seconded by representative alexander
supposed to be you yeah
okay
and do you want to address your
amendment uh thank you mr chairman mr
chairman the freedom life protection act
has only been in effect for a couple of
months but it's been under attack
ever since the day it passed or even
before
the major objection that's been
expressed about this act is the
requirement for an ultrasound for all
abortions
but
even though the act is constructed in
such a way that it looks like that
it isn't it doesn't do that
because the uh
but in any event
in order to obviate that objection
i offer this amendment
which specifically says in the same
paragraph
that
imposes
the ultrasound
this subdivision shall be construed
to require the performance of an
ultrasound only if the provider either
knows that the fetus has a gestational
age of 24 weeks or is conscious of a
substantial risk that the fetus has a
gestational age of 24 weeks so
to add to the compromise that the
freedom life protection act already is
this language clarifies that the major
objection that's been expressed on
ever since it passed
isn't valid
or has no strength
okay
so as i understand that this replaces
the entire bill
with the provision with regard to the
ultrasound is that correct it does
replace the entire bill with this
provision
of the ultrasound yes
questions or comments
representative alexander thank you mr
chair and i appreciate representative
walper for bringing forward this
amendment um this addresses um my major
concern that i had um regarding the
ultrasound mandate in september um i
would say that this does goes a long way
to clarify the mandate um it also set i
mean it in ultrasound
knowingly at least 24 weeks is not a
transvaginal ultrasound a standard
medical procedure would be it would be a
typical belly rub
non-invasive i appreciate
you bringing forward this amendment and
it addresses concerns i think it helps
clarify and strengthen
the modest fetal life protection act
thank you
other questions or comments
i i just want to say i
i would not support the original bill
which in effect repealed the fetal
health protection act
but i believe that that act is subject
to
some qualification and this being one of
them and would support your amendment
but would support other qualifications
as well
any other discussion
seeing none we'll take a vote on your
amendment
on the adoption of amendment 0688
to house bill 1673 representative mclean
yes
representative sylvia yes
representative walpervolt yes
representative alexander yes
representative greene representative
notter yes representative mariner yes
representative kelly
represent look at the wrong sheet
representative doucette yes
representative andres yes
representative smith yes
uh representative almi
representative oregon yes representative
diorenzo yes representative chase yes
representative kenny yes
representative langley yes
representative macbeth yes
representative page yes
representative simpson yes
mr chairman yes i have a 21 in the
affirmative zero in the negative
okay we have adopted amendment 068 and
we are now open to further amendment
representative
smith thank you very much mr chair um i
would like to move otpa
on amendment 073
[Music]
and is that seconded
representative simpson's seconds
and would you like to address your
amendment
thank you very much mr chair i would and
i have to address my amendment by
beginning first
to say
my heartfelt thank you
to my colleague
the clerk of this committee
the clerk of the committee listened
carefully
to testimony
that was difficult for all of us to sit
through
and
he did hear
come to understand the ambiguity
the perceived ambiguity in language
having to do
with the ultrasound
i believe
that the language that was passed
quite inappropriately and without any
hearing and without any deliberation
in the finance committee to add
inappropriate
to house bill 2 language that had
nothing to do with the budget
that language was very vague and it was
perfectly understandable
that
reading that language would cause
anyone to believe
that an ultrasound examination including
an an intrauterine
ultrasound
was going to be required
for anyone in this state
undergoing
a legal abortion remember none of this
applies at all
to illegal abortions that go on
in back alleys and my hope is that we do
everything we can to eliminate those
representative welper's
suggestion was i thought appropriate
and while left to my own device i might
not include the 24 weeks
the 24 week
restriction is not
unreasonable
want at least one and maybe all i don't
know because i haven't done all the
research but at least one of the
major
legal
licensed
entities that
provide a whole range of services only
one of which
is abortions
they do not provide abortions after 16
weeks
16 weeks is roughly
four months
so
certainly 24 weeks is not inappropriate
and i thank
uh the representative for his amendment
i was very happy to be able to vote for
it
but i see that as a floor not as a
ceiling there are a couple of other
items that were included in
house bill 2
that i also think
are
deserving of
elimination
they basically
come down
generally
to my
consistently held belief
that the legislature has no business
in
the doctor's office that these decisions
should be made
by
the woman and those people who she
chooses to involve including her the
medical professionals
and her family her religious whomever
else
but if in fact
we are going to involve ourselves
in
in these issues then i think we have to
make sure
that we recognize
that we have to have
some other
limits
the first
change
that i want to include
is one having to do with
fetal
anomalies incompatible
with
life
and i believe
that that is something
that we
should acknowledge
it happens it doesn't happen
always it doesn't happen universally but
when it does happen
it is an incredibly painful circumstance
and difficult
new reality
for someone who was pregnant and who has
looked forward
to having a baby and or everything that
comes from that i of course know that
the most important thing that comes from
pregnancies and babies is that they grow
up and they marry
and they produce grandchildren and
nothing is more important than
grandchildren so i believe
in those those pregnancies
going on
but sometimes there are fetal anomalies
those are not something that the
legislature can decide that is something
that
a medical professional
can decide with whatever additional
help they need
so
i would like to add and as is added in
my amendment
line 10 except in the cases
of
a case of fetal anomalies incompatible
with life
that's one change
the next change
that i wanted to make was to include in
line 29
not just the life
of
of the the the
pregnant uh woman
but also
her health
so it reads the life or health of the
pregnant woman whose life is endangered
by and then go on
and i think that health is is a very
important addition
and so there are
two changes
that i want to make the next changes
that i want to make
in house bill 2
where none of this belonged in the first
place
is to remove
the criminal penalties
against health care
providers and the civil
penalties against
health care providers
are licensed by the state
there are standards that they must meet
there are provisions
um
whether they're whether they're
setting the bones in my arm or my leg or
whether they're
um their obstetricians are involved in
gynecologists involved in
delivering care for pregnant women
we are talking about people where we
recognize the obligation of the state
to license
and the opportunity of the public
whether it be the patient or anyone else
to question
the
the responsibility the decisions that
are made all of that is already in law
to add
criminal penalties
having to do with whether or not
or having to do with how they they they
function in cases uh dealing with
pregnant women i think
creates a chilling of a chilling
environment
we have enough problems in this state
and we see it all over the state not
only in rural areas but also in urban
areas
in attracting
qualified trained licensed medical
professionals to come and do their jobs
and we expect to hold them accountable
to the standards that exist
in this state and i have no problem with
that what i do have a problem with
is creating
the appearance
that somehow
how they perform
in this area
differs
from the standards that they are
expected to perform in every other area
of how they deliver
hell responsible reliable health care
so i have
in this amendment
done just those things i have
enthusiastically added
representative welfare's uh 24-week
limitation
including the possibility
of um
of an ultrasound if that is necessary to
determine the 24 weeks
but i have added fetal anomalies
incompatible with life
not just a fetal anomaly but a fetal
anomaly incompatible with life
to this
um
i have added the health of the mother
and i have said
let's not arbitrarily put in here
a restriction and i'm going to stop now
because i saw
the uh
chairs body language and he wants me to
stop
and i almost always not always but i
almost always do what the chair wants me
to do
representative maclean
thank you mr chair um i just had a
question for representative smith if
that's okay of course okay well thank
you representative smith for taking my
question so i think fetal anomalies
incompatible with life in my mind
is something pretty well defined and i
can kind of get my head around it but
you also add
an exception for health and
health is
not i think very well defined and and so
because of that my concern is that it
may erode some
of the effectiveness of the bill so did
you give any thought to maybe
expanding the definition of health or
are you aware of case law out there that
basically has already kind of settled
down on what that definition is thank
you thank you i think it's a legitimate
question if you look the sentence goes
on it just it doesn't say
um
just
health you know which says you know then
whose life is endangered by physical
disorder physical illness or physical
injury
including
and then it it goes on
so that i believe that that language um
narrows
narrows it down thank you very much
representative representative mclean
you'd like to follow up thank you mr
chair so um so in in your understanding
then um
by adding on some of the the follow-on
definitions are in there let's say a
woman was to get pregnant and as a as a
result of that pregnancy and i'm not a
doctor so maybe this happens or doesn't
um she gets
severe migraines you know but the
thinking is that maybe once we go past
the pregnancy um those would not be a
persistent thing not something that
would not endure past a pregnancy would
that be considered health or no that
would be something that this would in
your opinion not be covered
fortunately it's not my opinion that
matters because what i have stated all
along is i am not a physician i am not a
doctor i am not in that room
with the patient
and it would be a medical professional
who could say
situation x
may or may not have been caused by the
pregnancy but has been exacerbated
exacerbated by the pregnancy cannot be
cured or would not disappear unless the
pregnancy ends and that to me is a
decision that should be made
by medical professionals not by
legislators who have all kinds of skills
but no skill in this
thank you representative notter
one quick comment thank you mr speaker
mr chairman um the abortionist promote
it again
the abortionists in new hampshire are
not required to be licensed
any other questions or comments
representative horrigan
um
well i attempted to answer the question
about abortion is being licensed but i
guess i'll pass on passed on that one
obviously it has to be done we're
talking here about
physicians who are licensed and um i
suppose
i feel there's other medical
professionals who might you might be
performing anyways anyway but i was
the we're coming we're adding the phrase
or health to the
paragraph sub paragraph three in line 28
through line one of the of the first
page in line to the second page and
there's
existing language that's not in boldface
because it's been there all along for
those two long months since the bill
took effect which
says uh when the continuation of
pregnancy would create a serious risk of
substantial and irreversible impairment
of a major bodily function as defined in
rsa 329 43
roman roman numeral five and that's a
fairly broad definition of uh
that's a fairly broad definition of a
major bodily function so pretty much any
bodily function is defined as a bodily
function so
because that's in the bill so there's
already is uh
protection here and this i believe is
putting that phrasing is just
strengthening strengthening it and there
is uh you know
we're already uh
we're just we're not putting anything
substantially new we're just
strengthening what's already there and
um
thank you
other questions or comments
okay
yes
thank you mr senator
so
i want to start with this repealing of
penalties
we talked earlier
you need to talk into the microphone i
think move it closer
we've spoken quite a bit about today
about the value of the life
and when we talk about the penalties
that are included in this bill
that's why they're there
because this is the only procedure we
know of
as far as i know it's the only one that
exists
where it involves the intentional
killing of a human
and in this case an intentional killing
of a human baby that could easily
survive
so there's that that
so i don't see if we remove these
penalties
we're devaluing
that human life
so that would be my first
objection
i
agree with
the representative from durham that the
qualifications following the words or
health
do does narrow
that exception
i don't think it now is it enough for
myself
to support the bill anyway but i have
plenty of other reasons to not
what i really want to talk about is
fetal anomalies incompatible with life
which i don't believe exist in today's
medical technology
about
about four years ago maybe six years ago
we had a bill similar to this in this
committee
and we had a vice chair of that
who was
what i want to call it very diligently
opposed to any exceptions at
all and we spent quite a bit of time
talking about
fetal anomalies incompatible with life
at that time
the only one
that could be identified
was
twin to twin transfusion syndrome
and the reason that no others could be
identified is because other anomalies
that we normally consider or did
consider even at that time incompatible
with life were being cured
by the technology that we have today so
today if you have
and i'm not going to try and even try
and use the medical terms because i'm
not that
so if you have a baby who's getting
fluid in the brain
and it's swelling and it would kill the
baby today they can go in and withdraw
that fluid
and that baby can proceed through its uh
more normal course of pregnancy
if you have a baby with an open brain
stem
they can go in they can take the womb
out open the womb perform surgery
on that baby and close those openings
and the baby can continue
i'll go back to twin to twin
transfusions uh transfer syndrome
for those that don't know that can that
consists of when there are two babies in
the womb
and they share the blood supply
so one baby
gets more one baby gets less that's just
the way it works
and that would be fatal to the one that
gets less blood
except even at that time and this is
several years ago
at the cleveland clinic the survival
rate of both babies
was over twenty percent the survival
rate of one
was way over not eighty percent
and i'm quite confident that they're
telling their technology has improved in
the years in between
so i don't believe there's actually any
fetal anomaly that's incompatible with
life so i would ask the
sponsor to identify one or two
thank you for the question and i would
say if there is no fetal anomaly
that what's the language incompatible
with life
then that language doesn't matter but
since i have no way of knowing that
because i am not a physician i am not a
geneticist i am not
technically uh
skilled in any of those decisions i
believe
that
uh that that should be left for medical
professionals and i
i do know
um
that
that's where those decisions should be
made if there if we have the most
wonderful medical system and there's
never an opportunity
for a fetal anomaly that cannot be
corrected so be it that's fine then
nobody can fall under this but i think
it's likely
representative
that there are fetal anomalies and i
want to make sure
that
women
and their families are protected in that
situation
follow up so
we already know that not all
abortionists in our state
are required to be licensed
but even beyond that
if
it's my understanding that
typical medical practice if if
a doctor performs an operation and the
patient
dies or there's death involved that
there's another autopsy
to determine if in fact the diagnosis
was accurate what the what this what the
doctor did was correct
how do we know
that anybody
who wants to violate the 24-week
abortion ban couldn't just claim
that there was some fetal normally
incompatible with life right and that
that's what they're putting in if they
don't normally incompatible with life
how do we know that there actually is
such a thing
in the case
where the law is violated
i guess i can't answer that question i'm
not going to go through
you know the looking glass with you and
say what if what if what if
we live in a world in which
sometimes things happen that not one of
us would
would tolerate or want or expect what
we're doing here is trying to pass
reasonable legislation
that in fact
honors the uh
our commitment to
law
to medical standards
to all kinds of
behavioral limitations and respects
the right of a woman
faced with a difficult situation
to get the best professional guidance
she can in making a decision and i i you
know
do i think someone might be outside
there right now
you know breaking into my car of course
somebody might be can i control that
well no but there are laws to make sure
that if they're doing that
and they get caught they can be held
responsible and it's certainly the same
thing holds true
whether you're a bricklayer
or an or an obstetrician or even a
legislator no no that's not true we're
exempt from so many things
i think truthfully i'm not going to
answer any other questions because i'm
afraid that the chair is really going to
get
annoyed with me and i would never want
that to happen
so
last statement
representative oprah you want to just
follow up with the last statement what i
get from that
is that we have created an opportunity
here
for anyone who so desires
to violate this bill
with no accountability
because there's no check on whether or
not the reason given
is in fact true
and no penalty
even if it is true i mean even if it's
not true
which effectively makes this a
useless piece of law
so i'll be voting against the amendment
i'm surprised to hear that
representative we don't need to comment
so representative macbeth
thank you mr chairman
i'm i'm shocked at the statements that
i've been hearing that a couple of my
colleagues have made that there is the
unauthorized unlicensed practice of
medicine going on in new hampshire and i
i'm not sure if they're talking about
the dispensing of a morning after pill
by someone that it's not but to say that
if that's occurring i think that that's
an issue for
i mean if people are illegally
practicing medicine i think that needs
those colleagues should bring that
forward
and
if not i that is really an outrageous
claim and i'm concerned about the
misinformation that people that might be
hearing and listening to this
um
might
think about new hampshire and about
our laws and the operation of this
committee if that if those comments keep
being made without
being
challenged or asked
you know at least some other time this
might not be the right time but i i just
think those are
spreading of misinformation is wrong
thank you representative army
thank you i think what
your colleagues are saying
is that they are not licensed
specifically to do abortions but they
are obstetrics and gynecology
licensed
doctors this
the law that was passed directly affects
our ability to have
gynecology and obstetrics doctors in
this state
i
am from lebanon
lebanon is the center of dartmouth
hitchcock my father
helped restart the medical school many
years ago
on
they
can
if they are
told that
if they are faced
well let me go back a second we have
lost most of the gy ob
obg
doctors outside of major medical centers
in this state already
there
there are too few babies being born they
have had to consolidate
into major centers
on
if
if a woman is having major trouble
with her
pregnancy she gets bumped up
from berlin
to lebanon or from berlin to concord
or
[Music]
or someplace like that
if they
on
if they are having a major problem and
they land
on
at the desks of the top
ob gyn people in new hampshire which is
what usually would happen
when it's a major problem and urgent
that doctor is faced with
in some cases very rare cases but they
are faced
in their practice with
am i going to allow this woman to die or
am i going to do an abortion
and
you try recruiting people to come
and join the few ob gyn doctors we have
in this state
when that is hanging over them
what we're doing is making sure that
women are not going to have adequate ob
gyn care
if we keep that on the books thank you
representative notter
thank you
it is true that that in new hampshire
there is no law that says that
abortionist has to be licensed so maybe
that somebody wants to put in a bill to
to fix that to make sure that they're
licensed um i my second question is for
representative wolper is everything that
you were describing uh like the worth of
a person and what's an anomaly whatever
does that fall under the category of
eugenics
well it kind of it does
it could
but in the context of this bill
i don't believe it does
unless you say that down syndrome which
is trying to be was being more or less
successfully eliminated in various
countries
by the process of abortion
uh if you consider that to be um
incompat and a fetal anomaly
incompatible with life or
for somehow other falling outside the
scope of this
than it would but
there you go
okay
other yeah representative horrigan
yeah so well maybe i don't need to
be just a horse but there are um i mean
the law does apply to anyone
who's uh providing who doesn't abortion
regardless of whether or not they're a
licensed uh healthcare professional but
as others have pointed out
you definitely do you need to be a
licensed physician or an allied
profession then you do need to be
and um you do need to be uh certified so
it is illegal to practice medicine
without a license um
the best i know and i don't if there
isn't a pacific i'm pretty i'm pretty
sure probably is correct that there is
in the pacific
chapter the rsas about uh abortions but
um that would
that'd be subject for another
oh was i going on too long and also uh
yes so
anyway they're
neither the
hospitals nor the smaller reproductive
health sillies i quite i can be quite
certain that none of them are
having
unlicensed professionals provide uh
surgical services such as abortion or
any services that they're all properly
licensed and certified and it would be
cycle
okay
are we
we've had a pretty good discussion are
we ready to vote
okay this is this is on the amendment
this is on the amendment
offered by representative smith
mr clerk do you want to call the roll
on the acceptance of amendment 0730 to
house bill 7
1673 representative mclean no
representative sylvia oh
representative walper votes no
representative alexander no
representative green
representative notter no representative
no representative kelly
representative doucette
representative andres no representative
smith yes
representative
representative oregon yes representative
diorenzo yes representative chase yes
representative kenny yes representative
langley yes representative macbeth
representative page yes representative
simpson
mr chairman yes
uh 2 4 6 8 9 11 and positive and then
ten in the negative
you've adopted the
you've adopted amendment 0.730
and is there any other discussion on the
bill we've had a pretty thorough
discussion here
if not
you could call the roll this is on the
motion of ought to pass as amended on
house bill 1673
with amendment 07 actually with
amendment 0688 in amendment
0730. right so just a question mr
chairman yep
since uh representative smith and
simpson uh authored the uh sponsoring
amendment can we call this ought to pass
as amended by them uh
you can and i definitely will have
representative smith do the majority
report on this
and have representative simpson do the
pi if that should be necessary
on the question of house bill 1673
ought to pass is amended with amendment
representative mclean
no
representative sylvia
representative walper votes no
representative alexander
representative greene
representative notter
representative merner
representative kelly
representative doucette no
representative andrus no representative
smith yes representative all me yes
representative horrigan
representative diorenzo yes
representative chase yes
representative kenny
representative langley yes
representative macbeth yes
representative page yes representative
simpson yes
mr chairman yes i have an 11 in the
positive 10 in the negative
and representative wilper um would you
like to do a minority report it would be
yes sir
mr chairman and that would be itl
that would be itl
no
oh it would be epa otpa
with my amendment
okay is there any other
business that we need to address here
today
i'd like to have everybody do their
their
my majority of minority reports by next
wednesday if that would be okay if i
could get it by wednesday
i had everybody do them very quickly the
last time because i thought we'd get
them all on the calendar and of course
they didn't get in the calendar so
but i think if i got them by wednesday
we could have them done by and submitted
by the end of next week
do you have any word on when we're
likely to be meeting again and where
i heard that i heard the second week of
march but i don't have a specific date
and i suspect it will be back in
representatives hall but
um i don't i don't know exactly i heard
perhaps around the 10th but i i don't
know for sure that's what i heard
in any event uh
thank you everybody you know tough
discussions today and tough bills today
but this is all the house bills that
we've gotten out
and we've did that
very well
and appreciate everybody's cooperation
and now we should have i have not
received any senate bills yet
so
we definitely will have next week off
and perhaps two weeks off at least
before we start we meet again
and so enjoy it
take care thank you everybody
yes
all right
um
texas
oh that's too bad wasted two years
have a wonderful holiday weekend thank
you youtuber it was nice seeing you
and i'm glad you're better
so glad
hello
now
down
hopefully we'll
had enough
what's nice
really
dnc's
i don't know
yes
so
you